nice I got no tea everyone were they
happy I'm sitting with my friend yeah
you both have the same birth dates which
I find is very interesting same August
31st
we do yeah it's cute I know that oh you
didn't know that I knew that I didn't
know it first
you've never told me that August 31st
this is a really bizarre that explains
so much cuz we're not really burgers you
know you're the cusp well yeah I don't
know what the mix is but we're not like
a normal he's more like a normal burger
actually than I am
okay I know nothing about that but I've
I'm happy to share the birthday with my
dude I'm wondering if you two were
simpatico this was actually gonna be my
last question but let's do it now I mean
did you feel you must feel sort of so if
you have a similar birthday there's
maybe some sensibilities similar traits
maybe not I'm reading too much into it I
think as far as this film goes okay I'm
Richard Gere's inter Norman okay well so
if there is an inter Norman and Richard
here then some of it is on this side of
the shot there's there's no question
that the eight or nine months that we
spent together there was a point where
you had revealed your inner Norman
enough to me that I went ah ha that's
where I'm going with this but you know I
do have to say just just for the record
between us please I think part of the
fun of working with Norman is that
Norman goes further than what I win
Everwood so there might be something of
Norman in me but I I hold it back in the
movie he just lets go which is fun it's
great fun then you were also were
generous enough with me that you allowed
that inner Norman to emerge and scream
once in a while so I could see how far I
could go with this
well I'm fascinated by your take on
watching Richard change into this
character this is not a normal character
for you to play usually your bliss or
that long before any
I mean this is a completely unique
character and for sure I mean it's a big
distance for me to play him but I I
think in reality a big distance for
anyone to play this guy he's written a
completely unique character how was it
to watch him transform in terms of body
language the way he carried himself his
his interactions with others his
personal space I think I think that the
biggest satisfaction that I have is when
each each scene has what the scene is
about but then there's this little
nuance it has to do with what the
character is really going through and it
usually has to do with his this
motivation that he has a no one else
knows he's trying to get close to
someone he's trying to introduce someone
to someone it's not the obvious thing
and seeing Norman seeing Richard grab on
to that small nuance and bring it to
life and express it in some way was
incredibly satisfying to me because it's
as if he was revealing this secret about
what really goes through Norman's head I
remember him directing me I'm flashing
on when the early scenes was actually
the first scene that's in the movie and
I'm approaching Dan Stevens in the park
I got a deal I'm trying to convince him
I remember we were doing the shot as we
as he moves away because he basically
does it no one wants anything to do with
this Norman or any Norman it's it's how
do you make them stop
without using losing your own dignity in
making them stop yeah and you see that a
lot with characters in this movie who
just they don't want have to say go away
leave me alone it's it's some level of
please enough
so I'm chasing I'm chasing we're doing a
Steadicam shot and he's saying remember
this direction was you know maybe you
could just kind of Bob behind him and
try to get his attention
well you're coming behind and it was so
I mean I got it immediately what you
were talking about and that ended up
informing much of what I did in a film
this sense of peaking peaking over
someone's shoulder and just waving I'm
still here is
is hi seeing Richard Gere do that it's
incredibly satisfying
you